herzlich willkommen in meiner torten
welt zuerst einmal wünsche euch allen
frohe ostern und hoffe ihr genießt eure
zeit mit der familie und ich möchte mich
ganz herzlich bei allen bedanken die
mich am mittwoch im globus besucht haben
es hat mich wirklich sehr gefreut hier
könnt ihr auch mal sehen ungefähr wie
viele leute da waren einige haben sich
nämlich auf dieser torte verewigt und
zwar habe ich hier eine styropor torte
also einen dummy mit von dort überzogen
und dann durfte meine besucher mit
lebensmittel stiften hier auf der torte
unterschreiben und diese torte ist
daraus geworden
ich habe die bilder auch schon bei
facebook gepostet und vielleicht habt
ihr euch ja schon drauf entdeckt ihr
habt vielleicht auch gesehen dass es in
meinem schotten upgrade gegeben hat und
zwar habe ich jetzt ein ganz neues shop
layout und da würde ich mich freuen
wieder mal vorbeischaut denn jetzt ist
der shop richtig hübsch geworden und ich
freue mich da richtig drauf auch auf
viele neue produkte und jetzt jetzt auch
so sein dass es für jedes produkt dann
mit der zeit jetzt immer ein video gibt
und zwar werde ich euch da in so kleinen
kurzen videos einfach zeigen wie man die
produkte verwendet und wie sie eben
gebraucht werden einfach damit jeder
sich vorstellen kann was es für ein
produkt ist was es beinhaltet und wie
man es verwendet heute möchte ich euch
ein rezept vorstellen für welches sich
schon viele anfragen hatte und zwar
mache ich heute eine 40 meldet orte also
eine sich hubert orte und dieses rezept
habe ich bereits letztes jahr gemacht da
ist aber mein filmmaterial verschwunden
und deswegen habe ich heute das rezept
für euch und möchte jetzt erst einmal
den biskuit teig backen und zeigt euch
dazu die zutaten bevor ich starte lege
ich mir immer mein blech zurecht oder
meine form und zwar benutze ich hier
heute wieder ein backblech aus meinem
back starterset meine back folie diese
dauer politisch mehrmals verwenden kann
und hier habe ich meinen tortenring den
kann ich nämlich als backing benutzen
und später auch als tortenring bei dem
flachen hier ist der vorteil dass ich
hier markierungen habe wie groß ich ihn
einstellen kann der ist nämlich flexibel
und ich werde jetzt auf 26 cm einstellen
ihr könnt aber auch eine ganze
eine springform nehmen das habe ich mir
zurecht gelegt und kann jetzt den teig
machen für den biskuit teig braucht ihr
300 gramm zucker einen esslöffel
vanillezucker den habe ich selbst
gemacht
60 gramm mehl 60 g speisestärke und
einen halben teelöffel backpulver ich
werde den biskuit teig geht's in der
kitchenette verrühren
aber natürlich könnte das auch mit einem
handrührgerät machen zuerst gebt ihr
jetzt die eier in eure rührschüssel und
die eier weil ich jetzt schön schaumig
rühren und dann nach und nach den zucker
und den vanillezucker dazu gibt
wenn die eier creme dann richtig schön
aufgeschlagen ist also richtig weiß ist
man sieht ist hier deutlich dass sie
richtig an volumen zugenommen hat dann
könnt ihr die trockenen zutaten
hinzufügen und zwar werde ich dir jetzt
sieben einmal speise stellt mehl und
backpulver und es werde ich jetzt
vorsichtig mit dem schneebesen
unterheben
da dürft ihr auch nicht zu lange rühren
einfach so viel wie nötig aber nicht
mehr und es einführen muss jetzt sehr
schnell gehen
ansonsten kann es nämlich passieren dass
euer tag hier am rand ausläuft und der
ofen muss auf jeden fall vorgeheizt
seien auf etwa 190 grad
und dann gebe ich jetzt hier ganz
schnell den teig rein und stelle dann
sofort in den ofen damit einfach der
teig hier am rand nicht auflaufen kann
wenn ich den teig in einer springform
back tone seine back rahmen dann dürft
ihr nur den spring vom boden fetten aber
nicht die ränder weil ansonsten der teig
nämlich runter fällt hier am rand und
teuer bis später nicht so schön hoch
wird also der rand darf nie eingefettet
werden bei biskuitteig das verteile ich
jetzt noch ganz schnell
und dann geht es wie gesagt sofort in
den strophen der biskuit teig muss für
etwa 20 minuten bei 175 grad ober
unterhitze gebacken werden
und zwar habe ich vorhin meinen ofen auf
190 vorgeheizt dass ich mir auch ganz
wichtig dass ich immer ein paar grad
höher vor hitze dann schiebe ich den
teig heben hinein mit dem bug rahmen
und dann schalte ich den herd wieder
zurück einfach damit der teig so ein
bisschen so eine schockstarre bekommt
nicht ausläuft und ich einfach weiß dass
der ofen richtig schön vorgeheizt ist
und da müsst ihr auf jeden fall die
stäbchen probe machen
dazu nimmt dir ein zahnstocher stechen
nennt hinein und wenn da nichts mehr
dran kleben bleibt dann ist der teig gut
die stäbchen probe dürfte allerdings
nicht vor 15 minuten machen weil sonst
der teig in sich zusammenfällt und ihr
dann keinen biss gezeigt hat
jetzt habe ich das hier zwei minuten
abkühlen lassen und kann jetzt hier mein
werkzeug benutzen dass ich nicht spitz
die sich kein messer sondern einfach so
raus wie so eine palette zum abtrennen
des tages das kann ich hier außen
ansetzen und kann es dann hier am arsch
schön abziehen
ich kann das auch und jetzt zieh ich
erst mal das blech darunter weg und hier
sieht man dass es ganz leicht
ausgelaufen ist aber so ein ganz kleiner
rand den könnt ihr eigentlich nie
vermeiden
mehr dürfte ist jetzt nicht sein das
heißt euro offen muss immer vorgeheizt
sein und ihr müsst den teig direkt in
die form geben und direkt in den ofen
schieben
ansonsten läuft euch der teig nämlich
von der form raus und das darf nicht
passieren da gibt's noch mal ein trick
wie man das vermeiden kann aber diesen
trick zeige stadt in meinem nächsten
video in dem ich mein bike starterset
vorstelle
jetzt lege ich hier ein sauberes
geschirrtuch drauf und kann es einmal
stürzen und sie jetzt die folie ab das
geht wunderbar hier muss ich noch mal
kurz sodass ablösen und kann jetzt den
rahmen wegnehmen und ihr seht jetzt habe
ich einen wunderschönen gebackenen
biskuitteig
durch das nicht schön dekorieren das
doch gleich und zum abkühlen lege ich
jetzt einfach noch so ein tuch drauf und
lass' es jetzt einmal komplett abkühlen
wer möchte kann jetzt ihr zum beispiel
etwas likör oder saft darüber träufeln
und den biskuit damit pafl - beim aus
nach dem abkühlen sieht jetzt so aus
und ich habe mir jetzt hier bereits eine
tortenplatte zurechtgelegt jetzt müsst
ihr euch überlegen
möchtet ihr den tag so hoch lassen meine
es wirklich extrem hoch geworden
für die portion oder möchtet ihr dass er
lieber etwas niedriger ist also ich
möchte dass er so dass unten teig ist
und dann drüber eine creme kommt und
dann kein teil kommt und mehr besitzen
ein bisschen zu hoch deswegen werde ich
den teig jetzt kurz etwas dünner
schneiden habe jetzt einfach mal
umgedreht
jetzt werde ich hier mit seiner torten
säge den boden verteilen und kann jetzt
hier einstellen
wie hoch ich den teig haben möchte ich
hatte so eine torten säge schon mal von
lidl oder aldi wales und die waren nicht
so gut weil die einfach hier glatt waren
bei dieser draht war glatt und da hat da
eben gar nichts geschnitten zum
einstellen drückt ihr das jetzt so ein
bisschen nach unten und könnt dann den
draht oben verstellen und hier daneben
einrasten lassen und dann schaue ich mir
das mal an ich möchte mein tag etwas so
hoch und lasse es eben jetzt einrasten
auf beiden seiten
und jetzt kann ich diese säge ansetzen
halte hier mit der hand fest und sage
jetzt ein haltlos
das geht natürlich am besten wenn der
teig nicht mehr so frisch ist also wenn
ihr das vielleicht einen tag später
macht aber ich möchte jetzt meine torte
gleich weiterverarbeiten
deswegen mache ich das direkt jetzt
werde ich erstmal den teig auf meine
platte setzen und kann jetzt den oberen
teil wegnehmen und den könnt ihr jetzt
irgendwie weiter verarbeiten könnte eine
kleine torte draus machen oder ist
zerbröseln und zu kates verarbeiten
aber ich werde diesen tag für diese
torte jetzt nicht benutzen jetzt kann
ich da einfach den tortenring meter
außenrum legen und stelle ihn soeben
wieder ein dass er von oben her passt
der muss einfach von hier oben jetzt die
torte richtig schön umschließen für die
creme braucht er jetzt folgende zutaten
und zwar 500 gramm quark ich habe zehn
magerquark ihr könnt aber auch einen
stichfesten joghurt nehmen also einen
zehnprozentigen 120 gramm puderzucker
den saft einer halben zitrone
ihr braucht vier teelöffel saab hart
das ist einfach so sahne steif mittel
einfach nur stärker und es ist einfach
rein pflanzlich und ohne gelatine
ihr braucht zwei becher sahne und ich
habe jetzt hier auch noch zwei tüten
magazine
die sieht so aus und wenn ihr die akad
ihnen nicht habt könnt ihr auch relative
nehmen und zwar zwölf blätter insgesamt
ich habe jetzt die akad eine weise
einfach pflanzlich ist die ihr braucht
natürlich die früchte hier habe ich 300
gramm tiefkühl früchte und zwar die
himbeeren
ihr könnt auch frische himbeeren
benutzen bei den tiefkühl früchten müsst
ihr sie einfach auftauen lassen das habe
ich jetzt schon und ich brauche 340 das
ist der aus der dose
den habe ich abtropfen lassen habe ihn
abgewaschen damit einfach nicht mehr so
süß ist und das ist er jetzt zuerst wäre
jetzt die sahne steif geschlagen
und dazu gebe ich sie hier in meinem
schiene können natürlich auch wieder
alles ohne küchenmaschine machen und mit
einem handgerät direkt die 400 gramm und
da gebe ich jetzt natürlich meinen
spritzschutz drauf du mit mir hier nicht
die küche voll spritzt und während die
sahne jetzt gerührt wird werde ich das
denn ab 1 rühren und zwar vier teelöffel
und ich verwende jetzt zudem esslöffel
aus meinem shop und zwar kann ich da
immer ganz richtig dosieren
ich habe jetzt hier in den esslöffeln
ein teelöffel einen halben teelöffel um
ein viertel teelöffel und da weiß ich
immer ganz genau dass die mengen stimmen
und wer jetzt hier diesen teelöffel
berlin da kann natürlich den ring weg
machen dann sind einzeln aber ich
wünsche so im park eigentlich ganz gut
ich wasch dir auch nicht jedesmal weil
ich ja damit nur die trockenen sachen ab
messe
außer ihr benutzt natürlich das für was
flüssig ist dann können dass er
natürlich abwaschen
da müsste auf jeden fall aufpassen dass
ihr da die mess löffel aus rostfreien
edelstahl benutzt damit sie euch einfach
nicht an rosten und so halten die
ebenerdig
bei der saale müsst ihr natürlich
aufpassen dass sie nicht über schlagen
wird
die braucht jetzt noch gerade ein paar
sekunden und welche herausnehmen und in
den kühlschrank stellen so ist er
richtig gut
jetzt nehme ich einfach eine andere
schüssel und gebe jetzt den quark hinein
da kommt noch der puderzucker mit dazu
und stellt zitronensaft und es wird ist
einfach ganz kurz verrührt bis die
zutaten vermengt sind war's das auch
schon mit der küchenmaschine
die früchte werden getrennt voneinander
pürieren und zwar gebe ich sie dafür in
seinen kleinen mixa rein und ich höre
jetzt auch zuerst die pfirsiche weil ich
die zuerst brauchen
die gebe ich jetzt in einen kleinen topf
und gibt da auch direkt die akademie mit
dazu und verrühren schön und lass das
jetzt aufkochen und dann muss es ab dem
zeitpunkt zwei minuten lang weiter
köcheln
wenn ihr jetzt statt mit der akademie
mit gelatine arbeitet müsst ihr auf der
packungsanleitung an nachschauen wie es
verarbeitet bei blatt gelatine ist es so
dass er die vorher ein weicht und
daneben in der warmen lösung hier auf
lösen könnt und bei gemahlene statine
ist es so dass ihr diese vorher in
wasser auflöst und dann eben hier mit
dazu geben könnte genau das gleiche
mache ich jetzt auch hier mit der
himbeere
wenn es um zwei minuten gekocht ziehen
wir es vom herunter schalten die
herdplatte aus und es lasse ich jetzt
weniger minuten abkühlen das ist einfach
nicht mehr so arg heiß ist dass es ganz
kurz hier stehen und rührt es einfach
gelegentlich auch wenn das fruchtpüree
dann leicht abgekühlt ist könnt ihr es
in ein kleines gefäß geben
es darf auch nicht zu klein sein ich
weiß noch sahne und quark mit dazu
kommen und jetzt gebe ich hier erst mal
nur einen löffel vom quark mittel und
verrührt es schön miteinander einfach
damit dieses fruchtmus jetzt nicht zu
schnell verliert und dann so kleine
stückchen drin habt und jetzt kommt da
einfach die hälfte des quartett rhein
und die andere hälfte geht wir auf
diesem berg
das wird jetzt kurz verrührt und jetzt
habe ich hier direkt noch die hälfte
meiner sahne mit rein kann mir das hier
so ein bisschen markieren und kann es
jetzt hier schön mit unterheben
jetzt nehme ich meinen tortenboden und
verteile etwa zwei drittel dieser creme
auf dem tortenboden und das mache ich
jetzt so ich schiebe ist hier die creme
hier zum rand markiere mir hier so einen
teil das ist jetzt ein drittel
das sind zwei drittel und die zwei
drittel gebe ich jetzt hier mit rein und
werde sich darin schön verteilen und die
streiche jetzt mit einer palette so
ebenmäßig wie möglich und so glatt wie
möglich und dann gibt die die torte für
etwa zehn minuten in den kühlschrank bis
diese schicht anfängt etwas fest zu
werden
in derzeit bereite ich jetzt schon mal
die himba creme zu und zwar gehe ich
jetzt wieder einen esslöffel von der
quarkcreme zu den himbeeren verrührt es
kurz
und gebe jetzt die himbeeren mit dem die
quarkmasse und da kommt jetzt die
restliche sahne mit dazu und jetzt gebe
ich ein drittel dieser himba creme zu
der pfirsich creme dazu also das gleiche
spiel wie vorhin ich schieb die creme
hier vor markieren mehr ungefähren
treffen jetzt bleiben die zwei drittel
in der schüssel und das eine drittel
kommt hier mit dazu jetzt vermisse ich
die beiden die pace nicht creme ist
jetzt ein bisschen fest geworden ich
habe jetzt auch keine zehn minuten
gewartet ihr müsst ihr einfach
individuell abstimmen wie fest eure
creme schon ist jetzt gebe ich ganz
vorsichtig diese 40 himberg rehm darauf
so dass sich diese obere schicht nicht
zerstöre
denn wir wollen ja später die einzelnen
schichten schön sehen und verstreicht es
jetzt wieder schön mit meiner palette
ihr könnt hier für auch gerne euren
vollen land klettern nehmen dann kommt
ihr nämlich richtig schön rein könnte es
jetzt schon gast reichen
jetzt gebe ich es erneut für zwei drei
minuten in den kühlschrank
jetzt ist die oberfläche wieder ganz
leicht fest geworden und ihr müsst euch
da einfach bei allem dürfe aber auch
nicht zu schnell machen denn die
einzelnen schichten müssen ja festlegen
bevor ihr eben die nächste schicht drauf
gibt aber die restliche creme hier im
behälter darf eben auch nicht fest
werden also deswegen ist das so eine
sache wo er eben ganz aufpassen müsst so
und jetzt gebe ich hier
diese creme noch drauf ganz vorsichtig
das ist jetzt praktisch nur noch die
reine himberg rehm und so gebe ich jetzt
die torte mit den drei schichten in den
kühlschrank für etwa eine halbe stunde
bis die schichten fest werden
und dann mache ich weiter für die letzte
schicht braucht ihr 125 milliliter sagte
zwar habe ich jetzt hier hin besser habt
ihr könnt aber auch natürlich in anderen
roten saft nehmen was ihr gehabt aber
hier passt natürlich am besten
wir brauchen einen halben teelöffel
speisestärke einen teelöffel zucker wenn
ihr möchtet ihr könnt ihn auch weglassen
und ich verwende noch ein paar himbeeren
die sind bei mir tief gefroren ich gebe
jetzt auch wieder ins tiefkühlfach damit
sie einfach schön hart bleiben und fest
bleiben und solange hier das genie zu
bereiten
dafür gehe ich jetzt den saft einfach in
einen kleinen topf gebe speisestärke und
zucker mir dazu und verrührt sich schön
klümpchen frei zu lassen sich einmal
schön aufkochen
ich habs jetzt noch etwa eine minute
köcheln lassen und habe ich den herd
ausgeschaltet und nehmen den saft jetzt
vom herunter und lass ihn hier jetzt
etwas abkühlen und kann in der
zwischenzeit schon mal die himbeeren auf
der torte verteilen wird die torte noch
richtig gestellt und zwar gebe ich dafür
jeweils ein esslöffel von dieser von
diesem saftig ihm werden darauf macht
das ganze auch relativ zügig und kann
bis jetzt hier noch schön verteilen
indem ich das einfach hin und her
bewegen und so gebe ich die torte jetzt
noch mal für etwa vier stunden in den
kühlschrank
am besten aber über nacht damit sie
wirklich komplett auskühlen kann und
danach sehen wir uns wieder meine torte
weit über nach dem kühlschrank sie es
richtig schön abgekühlt und jetzt werde
ich einmal hier den tortenring lösen
dazu nehme ich jetzt einfach wieder mein
tortenring messer und setzt es hier am
rand an und kam dann benrath schön
ablösen und das hat einfach den vorteil
dass ich jetzt hier nicht aus versehen
in die torte reine rutsche weil es
einfach diese zwei teile hat wo eben
hier
der rand festgehalten wird und das
messer schön am rand entlang gleiten
kann
aber weil es nicht hat kann es natürlich
auch mit einem ganz normalen besser
machen und dann könnt ihr hier am rand
richtig schön diese optik sehen wir sie
mit ganz deutlich den biskuit teig dann
kommt diese 40 schicht dann die pfirsich
melba schicht und die himbeer schicht
und ganz oben eben dieser schöne frucht
spiegel
und wenn ihr das richtig genau ist also
mit den ein drittel und zwei dritteln
damit diese mittlere schicht dieser
gemischte schicht aus himbeeren und 40
auch richtig schön lila und jetzt könnt
ihr zum beispiel noch so einem ins blatt
darauf geben einfach so ein farbtupfer
in grün jetzt noch ein kleiner tipp für
die dekoration und zwar nehme ich mir
jetzt etwas weiße schokolade und ein
scharfes messer und wetter schoko späne
machen und zwar setzt jedes messer
flache an und könnte dann solche schoko
späne abziehen und die setzt ihr dann
einfach direkt auf die torte
sieht dann die fertige torte aus und ihr
könnt ihr natürlich dekorieren wie er
das möchte
und ich habe mich jetzt für die weiße
schokolade entschieden einmal klingt
kommt geschah an die tür muss die torte
ganz kurz warten
der osterhase war nämlich grad dabei der
sanierer ja dann kann ich essen bei uns
machen gerade die zwei nachbarskinder
davon unsere nachbarn und haben uns
dieses kleine ostergeschenk gebracht
zeigt euch das mal und es ist schön hier
bei uns willst du hier aufwand und da
ist es einfach noch so egal ob man zu
ostern feiert oder weihnachten feiert
oder nicht man schenkt sich einfach
gegenseitig was uns ja ganz tolle
nachbarn
vielen dank für das tolle geschenke
stoppte guckst auch meine videos ja
guckt mal dazu hat die er ihnen kids
ausgesprochen und mit lebensmittelfarbe
angemalt und kleine capex gebacken mit
seinem marshmallows lawinen und eine
schokolade obendrauf
auch will eckert die lassen uns gleich
schmecken und jetzt werden wir die torte
natürlich noch gemeinsam anschneiden und
probieren und dazu nämlich ein ganz
scharfes messer und schneidet mir jetzt
einfach eine schöne ecke raus wenn ich
nehme ich mit stelle ich hier noch so
eine kleine torte neckereien damit die
torte schön frisch bleibt und mir nicht
zusammenfällt
und jetzt muss die torte natürlich noch
probiert werden
das ist eine richtig sommerliche torte
also ich bin geradezu wenn es warm wird
muss man die torte unbedingt mal
probieren weil sie richtig schön nach
früchten schmeckt nach himbeere und nach
und falls ihr hobby sich nicht mit
könnte es natürlich auch austauschen und
andere farben benutzen
das rezept gibt es zum nachlesen auf
www.zdf.de ich würde mich natürlich über
einen kommentar freuen und auch über
eine bewertung und natürlich auch
darüber wenn ihr das video teilt ich
wünsche euch jetzt noch einen ganz
schönen sonntag natürlich noch schöne
ostern und wir sehen uns dann beim
nächsten mal wieder wahrscheinlich schon
am mittwoch mit einem kleinen
auch video und ich wünsche euch viel
spaß bis dahin bis dahin tschüss